hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba it's
day two it's a meme that's what he's in
different clubs I get sweaty leave me
alone we are going to watch today at the
new trailer Assassin's Creed Odyssey I
just got back any gaming this year way
behind on the games but Sammy actually
has played a lot of Assassin's Creed so
this is gonna be way more his video and
then my old-school Assassin's Creed I'm
the new gen school the new gen wasn't
for me give me the Ezio give me that
forgot the first guy's name it's a lump
it's long name Michael Fassbender
Michael so yeah but okay video games
about the games follows a me at the
underscore next once on Instagram he's
also part of the double toast of team
make sure to check them out on YouTube
hey let's hop right into this shall we
Sammy why is your voice like that you
know
classic classic go go follow salmon er
da minha cooler guy I'm around you
you're the cool guy I'm not
you got thank you showing me photos of
her before I didn't do any of that it's
like oh I got that was you've bested I
twist stories to fit my own agenda oh no
idea what that's like blood and gore
intense violence sexual theme okay
my girlfriend loves these games you're
old enough now this is my father spear
holds a certain burdens for 300 AD it
carries with it a long line of power
exactly 300 yep
the same blood courses through your
veins but it isn't enough to make you
unite the people of Greece for that you
will need courage
passion like burning yourself
commitment
nice I was like it's just standing there
taking Oh Zack Snyder's it's I did the
hamstring
kill that lion
gorgeous
waitwhat this Central American
seems like all the critics are talking
about the graphics I I mean it looks
beautiful
much archery bow what what journey which
I'm okay
Assassin's Creed Odyssey available
October 5th I am I'm genuinely surprised
by how this is being treated like the
300 sequel right right it's like a
hundred percent right they even had a
look at night it's in there they're
pretty much have liked the video game
scenes of the 300 exactly let's see
where they're lined up with that when
they were in the the valley that one was
that's in the movie this is like when
you watch like we made a video game of
300 watching that but one thing is
missing is that guy the voiceover the
mortals with their the entire like that
guy that's all this trailer maybe is 300
but then that ending bit Assassin's
Creed I'm very much it was into like the
Ezio ones like the four of those games
in is four of those
they got weird near the end it's like
the second one which was history to it
went like historical historical
historical then it went sci-fi yeah whoa
that blew my mind and this one goes
historical historical store cool sci-fi
again where they bring up the minutes
are the Cyclops Medusa and it's like
wait you're telling me there's a video
game with kind of like real historical
accuracy the great locations you have
the battles and where you can customize
your boat oh but no but like you you
customize that and then you're telling
you I can fight Medusa I can fight a
centaur or like whatever the hell out
there yeah back to that part right there
where he's slicing that dude up like one
he jumps like four inches and four feet
of the ground and that guy is dead three
slices in for sure and he's just like
nope gonna keep doing a three Thunder
style when I say this is like 300 I mean
more than just it's Spartans the way the
the fight scenes are captured with the
slow-mo then speed up everything it's
just it's great out of this the only
thing you need to do is just like up the
contrast yeah super high and then like
make the river really bright and that's
it it's 300
that's not necessarily a bad thing cuz
300 obviously touted for its visual
style yeah
so when you get a game that looks like
that that's a little more realistic that
headdress looks Central American I don't
know what that is I can you should be
another faction but that looks like a
Mayan dude so I mean it seems like a lot
of what the critics here that at least
are quoting are talking about its
graphics of course I want a game with
amazing graphics right what about the
game I don't know I mean nothing kind of
like crap assassins great games well
that was the thing that was the problem
that's why I stopped playing after Black
Flag because then they put out like for
years like Marvel yeah England France
and then there was extended kid or
whatever have you they waited for origin
to come out and then that was great
everyone's like oh I thought we were
done with desert read but that was like
a masterpiece and then this one's coming
out on say two years after okay
and I think this two years and this
looks beautiful it looks
historically accurate which is my
favorite part of these series is that
they're super kind of close to what the
world would be like then it looks
awesome badass fighting mechanics and so
it could go as far as that takes it just
the looks and just the immersion or it
can have a really good great gameplay as
well great story the hiccup here that's
interesting though is that you can be
both a male or a female in this game to
start
oh she goes my son so when that starts
you can play as a woman suspect my
daughter is she drops beer so you have
the option in this game so I wonder how
that is going to play into the story
mode because it's gonna be non
gender-specific you can be you can get
in relationships with both men and women
in this game so you could be a dude and
like romance a dude you could be a woman
romance a woman in this game that's how
it was back then and it's yeah I'm
kidding for those of you who are since
I'm kidding I don't believe in sarcasm I
don't know everything's literal the idea
is that I hope they don't make that
story so vague where it's like oh it
could just be person
Ezio was like a super charismatic he was
written well because you get to know him
over the course of these games so I hope
this main character who whatever the
name is I hope we can learn about them
and it's it's a rich story about them as
well so that's the only thing I'm
worried about like
you know where that savory just cut it
up that guy so that moment where he's
cutting him up is cool it goes on a
little too long I think what would have
made it cooler is instead of just blood
cutting out you're watching the guy
actually getting like slash oh I think
this is filty no is this team this is
beautiful it's stunning
over the top I wonder how like some of
the the less kind of obvious kills are
cuz the assassin's creed's obviously
about sneaking around yeah the hidden
blade and jumping this is just this is
just a lot of like [ __ ] dudes yeah
which is my split my style of play
I don't like hiding and like sneaking up
on a guy in slashing his throat I like
it running facing 70 guys because it's a
video game and I don't want to wait to
take out all these guys quietly I don't
know this seems like more my speed I
mean yeah no doubt about it it looks
really cool if you ever wanted to play
Zack Snyder 300 years right and who
wouldn't who wouldn't want that's this a
fair point as much as it's like as much
as it sounds like I'm giving it crap I'm
really I'm really not I'm just more
surprised by how it's exactly that the
movie yeah I mean that was such a
stylistically fun movie it was so bloody
it's so fantastical that why wouldn't
you translate that to a video game why
wouldn't you want to take some of those
300 because they didn't have the IP and
nobody's trying to do that but people my
age have like fond memories of 300 when
they were like teenagers like young
teenagers you're watching this like I
want to play that and there's monsters
and there's a giant statue that's
awesome
I want that I just can't wait to you
know be gay when you do Let's Plays you
get all the homos mad but why is that
dude kids no dudes like it's Sparta
that's what they did so they did why did
why is he playing as a woman because I'm
all for equality exactly well that that
was a big controversy was that they were
like it's too hard to make women
characters so we can't make him an
option they said that and one of the
versions like Ubisoft is like yeah it's
like super hard to make a woman
character the main character or a
playable character even though they had
done it before with one of the
playstation portable versions those very
successful games with females yeah it
was a weird controversy like the whole
Tomb Raider game stars
but it was like a weird thing where it's
like we can't make them interchangeable
and so this wasn't like oh now they're
interchangeable that's why I think
partially why they did guys what do you
think of this baby gender-inclusive
folks see I got you I got you [ __ ] none
non-gender pyromania no I'm on your team
I have five female friends and one black
friend one next I'm very Mexican so work
so he how are you doing - what are you
Italian and Filipino you know you don't
have to wear a hat you look like it's
really hot in here
he doesn't like those guys you can
subscribe to the region guys you get
inside of the what do they do is you
can't just subscribe in the list in the
reject nation you have to serve two
years in the military give me $5 PayPal
Sammy the next once on Instagram check
us on patreon we've got TV show
reactions q and A's and let's check out
Sammy on the double toast of channel him
and no one else it's just me forever
seeing a single toast is what they
should you have toasts and we know your
tricks